new in theaters this week bad times at
the El Royale and first man what will
you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
chris hemsworth Dakota Johnson Jon Hamm
Jeff Bridges Nick Offerman and more bad
times that the Ellroy out comes out this
weekend and yes it has a star-studded
cast but it also looks really cool the
story follows seven strangers all with
something to hide who find themselves
staying in a hotel that straddles the
border between California and Nevada and
1960s Lake Tahoe it has a really cool
Rat Pack meets clue blab going on and
the outfits oh yeah this movie is for
you if you like gritty crime stories you
love movies with a really great ensemble
cast or hotels kind of freak you out
some say Ryan Gosling is the only man
but this weekend he stars as Neil
Armstrong in first man the story of the
first astronaut ever to set foot on the
moon
from the director of la-la land and
whiplash Damien Chazelle first man is
sure to be a fresh take on one of the
most groundbreaking events in history
this movies for you if you like Ryan
Gosling and dozen historical dramas are
your thing or you feel like you know the
moon but you don't know know the moon
you know
ant-man and the wasp is now available
for streaming on Fandango now in this
sequel to the first ant man in the 20th
film in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
ant-man played by Paul Rudd again teams
up with you guessed it the wasp played
by Evangeline Lilly okay so it's a
little more complicated than that come
on Paul Rudd and Evangeline Lilly it's
basically a clueless lost universe
mashup this movie is for you if you love
what's left of the post Thanos snap
Marvel Cinematic Universe Paul Rudd as
an action hero makes you giggle in and
voluntarily clap your hands or like me
you're just now realizing that an
ant-man is just an uncle that
your weekend ticket what will you see
check back next week for Jamie Lee
Curtis has returned to the Halloween
franchise so I just think of Bryan
Gosselin